the new coronavirus SARS coughs you and
the disease it causes kovat nineteen is
spreading across the globe and as more
cases appear outside of Asia you're
probably starting to hear the word
pandemic the risk of a global pandemic
is very much upon us global pandemic
could become a pandemic with the
potential to become a pandemic let's
unpack what that word actually means and
how you can protect yourself going
forward so what is a pandemic simply put
a pandemic is a disease that spreads
globally crossing international
boundaries and affecting a large a
number of people to put that in context
here are a few other helpful definitions
so firstly we have this definition of an
endemic disease that means a disease
that's occurring at a steady predictable
rate then you have outbreak which means
a disease that's spreading well above
and beyond endemic levels an epidemic on
the other hand is an outbreak that
spread to a large geographical area keep
in mind that Warner disease can change
status over time now going back to the
p-word the classical definition of a
pandemic doesn't say anything at all
about disease severity it's really all
focused on geographic scale so far the
World Health Organization hasn't
referred to this as a pandemic our
message continues to be that this virus
has pandemic potential although many
epidemiologists myself included are
treating it as one the spread of this
new virus SARS cough tube is likely
passed the point of containment and
that's the first thing you try to do
with the potential pandemic it's what
China was trying to do with massive
quarantines the likes of which we've
never seen before but once you're past
that point of containment you need to
quickly pivot to another focus instead
of trying to stop a disease that's
already spread to many different
countries you need to focus on slowing
the spread of infection to do this you
have to properly isolate people who are
infected and try and quickly develop
treatment and vaccines it looks like at
least so far with this new virus that
the death rate is a lot lower than other
severe coronavirus
says that doesn't mean many people
haven't died we've seen thousands of
deaths but the overall death rate is
closer to around three percent for this
new virus whereas the death rate for
SARS was around 10 percent and for MERS
the death rate was over 30 percent now
just because this new virus doesn't seem
to have as high a death rate it doesn't
mean that we shouldn't have a plan so
how do we protect ourselves right now I
know this sounds really pedestrian but
trust me one of the best pieces of
advice is to wash your hands with soap
and water regularly have good coffee
jeans like cough into your elbow coffee
into a tissue and then throw it away and
also get your flu shot I know people are
kind of like over hearing about the flu
at this point but the reason I say it is
that if you get sick with the flu
it massively increases your risk of
getting a second respiratory infection
like the new corona virus also you can
practice what's known as social
distancing that means simply limiting
your exposure to other people by working
at home for example or if you're in
public maintaining a distance of 3 to 6
feet between you and others I'm getting
a ton of questions about masks
understandably so here's what you need
to know you need to our mask if you have
symptoms of respiratory disease symptoms
like coughing or if you're looking after
people who are sick and have those
symptoms you also need to know how to
properly use a mask and be aware of
things like once a mask is moist it's
not as effective and needs to be
replaced wearing a mask without full
knowledge of when and how to wear it can
be dangerous because it gives people a
false sense of security about how
protected they really are if you do need
a mask health authorities recommend a
regular surgical mask because that
prevents droplets from other people
coming into contact with your mouth and
nose and if you have symptoms it
prevents those droplets from you
reaching others an n95 mask is
recommended for healthcare workers
caring for sick people when they're
doing procedures that bring more fluid
up from inside a person's lungs
the more dangerous so that's why n 95
marks is recommended bear in mind that
with masks it's not one-size-fits-all
you want to make sure that a mask you're
wearing really is right for you and
really is working one way to do this
ideally you get a fit tested but also
when you put an n95 mask on you can do a
seal test where you breathe hard and you
feel to see whether any air is escaping
around it or not a question I get asked
a lot is should you are a mask if you
don't have any symptoms like just to be
really really safe the answer I normally
give is no because if you wear a mask
unnecessarily or you stock up on a ton
of them you're just contributing to the
mask shortages that we're already seeing
and taking away resources from people
who truly need them so for now take
advice from what your local health
officials are saying I think what
history tells us is that pandemics are
inevitable and to be expected and that's
really why we need solid pandemic
preparedness plans at national levels
and also at family and community levels
to understand just what pandemics are
capable of let's look at a few examples
from human history starting with perhaps
the most infamous pandemic the Black
Death or the bubonic plague
now this pandemic got its name from its
symptoms specifically lymph nodes that
became blackened and swollen after
bacteria entered through the skin lovely
I know now this isn't the first pandemic
by any means but it's certainly one of
the deadlier
it lasted from around 1346 to 1353 and
resulted in the deaths of somewhere
between 75 million people up to 200
million people it's mostly associated
with Europe but it's thoughts have
originated in Asia and then spread
across that continent as well as
possibly Africa there are a few theories
about how the disease spread to humans
some scientists say could have spread to
us directly from rats others say there's
some evidence that it was actually
spread by fleas that lived on gerbils
let's fast-forward to 1918 and here we
run into the Spanish flu pandemic which
infected one in three humans alive at
the time and killed about 50 million
globally it's only called Spanish
because Spain was not involved in World
War
and it was neutral therefore it did not
have a new censorship so when this
outbreak arrived in Spain that's when it
got press coverage rose in France and
other countries it was not mentioned in
newspapers at all the Spanish flu killed
really quickly there were approximately
25 million deaths in just the first five
or six months part of the reason for
that though probably had to do a lot
with poor living conditions at the time
and the fact that flu makes you
susceptible for other infections like
bacterial chest infections and back then
there were no antibiotics and unlike
what we're seeing today where it seems
that older people are more vulnerable to
death from kovat 19 at least based on
preliminary data Spanish flu was
different it was wiping out young and
healthy adults then there's the hiv/aids
pandemic HIV quickly spread from central
and western Africa to every continent on
the planet in the early 1980s and it's
killed more than 30 million people
around the world it's also the first
pandemic for which there's been global
activism and be very rapid development
of treatments it went through the whole
spectrum from being an outbreak to an
epidemic to a pandemic and now many
people say we can call HIV endemic in
some parts of the world thanks to
advances in medical technology and the
AIDS activist HIV should be a chronic
manageable condition that you live with
your whole life although ideally we'd
have a vaccine and a cure for HIV next
we have the Czar's pandemic which went
from 2002 to 2003 and was also caused by
a corona virus remember that's a whole
family of viruses including for corona
viruses that cause the common cold as
well as this new corona virus that
causes kovaydin 19 SARS likely jumped
from civet cats to humans in China and
then spread to other parts of the world
back in 2002 Chinese officials had a
delay in sharing data about SARS and in
response the World Health Organization
updated the international health
regulations basically to compel all 194
member states to get their act together
and meet specific standards for
detecting reporting and responding to
outbreaks these new plans for a more
coordinated global response to pandemics
came into effect with the 2009 swine flu
pandemic
which was caused by a new h1n1 flu virus
and killed between 150,000 to around
half a million people it spread pretty
widely it was seen in both northern and
southern hemispheres between April and
September of 2009 which means they also
spread outside of the normal flu season
we've learned from previous pandemics
that people can either die from the
disease at hand or develop immunity to
that disease and that means that as the
disease continues to circulate it won't
have that same devastating impact that
it did the first time around one example
of this is the h1n1 virus that caused
the 2009 flu pandemic that virus is now
a common flu virus that circulates
worldwide but it doesn't cause a
pandemic so how does a pandemic end
viral urges estimate that this new virus
will likely stay in China and continue
to seed other countries in the world
until maybe it just becomes as common as
the other four corona viruses that cause
the mild common cold some people are
even starting to call it the fifth
corona virus so maybe that will be its
story it goes from covert 19 which
caused this terrible situation to the
fifth regular corona virus causing the
cold some firewater just even predict
that maybe 40 to 70% of adults around
the world will become infected with the
new virus before this is all over but
many scientists still say the vast
majority of those who become infected
are more likely to have a milder version
of the disease what we have on our side
versus those poor people facing the
black death for example is we have the
capacity to more quickly develop
treatments and vaccines a covert 19a
vaccine candidate could be ready for
early phases of safety testing in April
and if that goes while testing could
begin to see if the vaccine actually
prevents disease by the late summer but
reality check it would still be 18
months at least after that that any
vaccine will probably be available so
yes you'll be hearing the p-word a lot
but remember definitions of pandemic
focus on geographic spread and do not
focus on severity of a disease
you